vielleicht kennen einige von euch dieses
video hier ein chirurg benutzt einen
riesigen apparat um mit unglaublicher
präzision die haut von einer traube
abzulösen was aussieht wie science
fiction ist tatsächlich realität der
roboter heißt da vinci und ist für viele
die zukunft des operierens seit dem
video sind mittlerweile zehn jahre
vergangen und die inzwischen dritte
generation der komplexen maschine wird
in tausenden kliniken rund um den globus
eingesetzt
aber hinter diesem beeindruckenden
fortschritt der medizin verstecken sich
unglaublich hohe kosten ein
monopolistischer konzern und vielleicht
gar nicht so viele vorteile für die
patienten
wir schauen uns heute an wie roboter
chirurgie genau funktioniert welche
vorteile sie tatsächlich hat und was ihr
noch im weg steht
wir durften bei einer echten roboter op
dabei sein alles mögliche filmen und
trigger morning wenn ihr kein blut sehen
könnt dann solltet euch dieses video
vielleicht besser nur anhören
außerdem schauen wir mal ob der roboter
selbst einem jubi mir helfen kann
wirklich besser zu operieren
hoffentlich verletzlichkeit
[Musik]
wie eine große sanftmütige spinne türmt
da vinci über den patienten und lässt
seine emsigen gliedmaßen grazil und vor
allem unglaublich präzise über den op
tisch tanzen
drum herum arbeitet das team aus ärzten
und anästhesisten dem roboter zu jeder
schritt in diesem gut einstudierten
ballett sitzt und der operateur nun der
sitzt ein paar meter entfernt und bahnt
sich per 3d brille seinen weg durch den
körper des patienten
wir sind in der urologischen
paracelsus-klinik in düsseldorf und
schauen doktor sieht man über die
schulter mit dabei ist auch sein tutor
doktor david er hat bereits mehrere
tausend operationen mit dem da vinci
system gemacht und ist somit eine echte
koryphäe auf seinem gebiet
seit 2006 arbeitet er schon mit dem
system und war damit einer der ersten
chirurgen in deutschland die sich an die
roboter chirurgie gewagt haben
seit etwas mehr als einem jahr betreut
er nun unter anderem druck da sieht man
und das fachteam für roboter assistierte
operieren in düsseldorf also wir haben
hier in golzheim natürlich ein sehr
schönes situation dass ich als trainer
sozusagen jeden tag bei jeder operation
hier mit dabei bin
bis ich davon überzeugt bin dass der
kollege den ich ausbilder auch genauso
gut überlegen kann die qualität bedienen
kann
ich mache das prinzipiell seit anfang
letzten jahres dann aber auch in vielen
einzelnen schritten von der simulator
training bis am training am lebenden
schweinen bis zum
erst eine operation in ganz deutschland
gibt es nur wenige an der kante trainer
für roboter assistierte chirurgie doktor
david ist einer von ihnen
coaches wie er bilden ärztinnen und
ärzte über mehrere jahre und viele
eingriffe hinweg aus und müssen dafür
extra von einer anderen klinik
herangeholt werden
das kostet natürlich geld aber so ein
intensives training ist essenziell um
mit dem roboter wirklich sicher
operieren zu können
denn fast alles unterscheidet sich
maßgeblich vom normalen op geschehen
nicht nur der ablauf der gesamten op
sondern auch wieder behandelnde arzt
arbeitet beim normalen herkömmlichen
operation ist wie essen mit messer und
gabel das kann man irgendwie man hat
halt schon mal eine pinzette unerkannt
gab man schon mal nadelhölzer in der
hand gehabt so das muss man bei den da
vinci system erst mal lernt von dieser
wenn ich gefühl von der haptik die man
normalerweise in den fingern hat muss
man das jetzt umlernen auf das gefühl
was man mit den augen dann bekommt und
das ist das schwierigste sache okay dann
wollen wir uns mal anschauen wie das
ganze genau funktioniert
[Musik]
das da vinci system besteht wie gesagt
aus zwei teilen der steuerkonsole und
dem eigentlichen op roboter einer der
roboterarme ist eine 3d kamera die
steuer operateur mit seinen füßen
während er durch eine art brille
hindurch schaut die anderen zwei bis
drei arme sind dann die eigentlichen
hände des operateurs die mit allen
möglichen werkzeugen ausgestattet werden
können mit den speziellen controller
macht die operierende personen die
bewegungen und der vinci für diese quasi
in echtzeit und vor allem skaliert aus
das heißt eine bewegung von etwa zehn
zentimetern mit der hand entspricht nur
etwa einem zentimeter
beim roboter greifen schneiden oder
nähen geht also um ein vielfaches
präziser und dank sieben bewegungs
dimensionen kann man alle bewegungen mit
der menschlichen hand auch mit dem
roboter darstellen
vielleicht sogar mehr außerdem werden
unerwünschte befehle wie zum beispiel
zittern der hände oder plötzliche
schnelle bewegungen vielleicht wenn man
angerempelt wird herausgefiltert
insgesamt sollen so weniger fehler
passieren und op ist sicherer sein
ob das wirklich so ist da ist man sich
tatsächlich gar nicht so sicher aber
dazu gleich mehr
diese präzision ist vor allem bei
besonders schwierigen operationen und
wichtig dazu gehört auch der eingriff
bei dem wir dabei sein durften die
sogenannte radikale prostatektomie dabei
wird eine von krebs befallene prostata
samt tumor entfernt das ist zwar ein
ziemlich standardmäßige eingriff der
aber dennoch nur von erfahrenen
chirurgen und chirurgen durchgeführt
wird
denn die prostata die tief im becken
umgeben von vielen knochen und sensiblem
gewebe und es damit nur schwer
zugänglich das organ auf so engem raum
zu präparieren erfordert einiges an
handwerklichem geschick und genau hier
erleichtert der roboter die arbeit
erheblich
also das system hat mehrere vorteile ich
habe an sogenannter dreidimensionale
bildgebung
sozusagen eine konsole alles
dreidimensional sehe weitere vorteile
sind dass sich zehn bis 15 fache bild
vergrößerung habe ich habe fast micro
chirurgische instrumente und so dass ich
in engstem raum mich bewegen kann und
auch agieren kann
dazu kommt noch dass das arbeiten mit
davinci auch deutlich gemütlicher und
ergonomischer ist die sitzhöhe und
abstände an der konsole können
individuell eingestellt werden damit sie
genau zu operierenden person passen so
sitzen ärzte und ärztinnen während der
teilweise stundenlang guppys angenehm
aufrecht anstatt sich ständig über den
op tisch zu beugen
und auch für den patienten ist ein
sogenannter minimalinvasiver vorgang wie
dieser wesentlich angenehmer als eine
herkömmliche offene operation die
einzigen schnitte die gesetzt werden
müssen sind gerade so groß dass die
schmalen kanäle hindurchgeführt werden
können das eigentliche operieren
passiert dann im körper stadt mit einem
großen offenen schnitt für den patienten
heißt das weniger blutverlust eine
schnellere genesung und besseres
abheilen mit kleineren narben solche
eingriffe werden von erfahrenen
operateuren natürlich oft auch ohne
roboter durchgeführt ein gerät wie da
vinci könnte aber deutlich mehr kliniken
ermöglichen schwierigere eingriffe mit
weniger komplikationen anzubieten
das setzt allerdings voraus dass die
kliniken sich diese hardware überhaupt
leisten können
der größte nachteil ist dass das system
sehr teuer ist also das heißt die
anschaffung die unterhaltung des systems
und das wird von den krankenkassen noch
nicht so entsprechend honoriert das
reparieren einen benefit davon hat ein
der vinci system kostet bei anschaffung
saftige 2,5 millionen dollar doch damit
nicht genug die instrumente die bei der
op zum einsatz kommen funktionieren
lediglich für zehn eingriffe bevor sie
ausgetauscht werden müssen
das ist laut hersteller in erster linie
eine sicherheitsmaßnahme denn wenn
instrumente zu häufig verwendet werden
arbeiten diese womöglich unzuverlässiger
praktischerweise bringt diese
sicherheitsmaßnahme den monopolisten
aber auch circa 2500 weitere dollar
mit jeder operation ein für das
krankenhaus kommen dann auch noch die
mehrkosten für generelle wartungen
versicherungen und nicht zuletzt die
bereits angesprochene ausbildung des
personals hinzu
letztendlich heißt das dass die
krankenhausträger aktuell mit jeder
roboter op draufzahlen
in deutschland sind das pro behandlung
im schnitt 2000 euro extra eine
gebärmutterentfernung kostet
krankenkassen in nrw zum beispiel sogar
fast das doppelte wenn da vinci zum
einsatz kommt dem unternehmen hinter der
vinci intuitive surgical wurde daher
schon häufig vorgeworfen seine
monopolstellung auszunutzen
ich meine soll dieses ding hier wirklich
mehrere tausend euro wert sein
klar in der medizin ist alles immer
teurer
immerhin gibt es hier einen
lebenswichtigen anspruch auf qualität
und zuverlässigkeit und das ist auch gut
so
trotzdem muss man sich die frage stellen
aber waren aus der not der patienten vor
allem profit geschlagen wird abgesehen
von ihrer preispolitik wurden intuitive
surgical auch schon andere unethische
methoden vorgeworfen
so sollen sie angeblich ärztinnen und
ärzten ohne entsprechende ausbildung
nahegelegt haben per roboter zu
operieren
außerdem seien wohl einige zwischenfälle
mit davinci vom unternehmen nicht
ordnungsgemäß gemeldet worden
was mich allerdings auch den gedanken
bringt was passiert eigentlich wenn das
system mal ausfällt dann ist es mit dem
internet verbunden dann hat man gleich
eine live schaltung zu den technikern
von den ttf selber die lesenden computer
aussagen welche fehler das ist selbst
wenn man ein gefäß festgehalten hat dann
hält es das war das fest egal ob es
wieder hochfährt oder nicht wo fährt das
ist bleibt geschlossen also dass es
sicher und das bewegt wenn eine
verletzung da passieren sollte und es
blutet muss man offen europa reden da
muss man immer bereit sein die
hoffentlich wird es immer geben und wie
wird niemals auch durch den roboter
nicht wegfahren
obwohl der vinci für die operieren so
attraktiv zu sein scheint waren 2018 in
ganz deutschland nur 85 da vinci roboter
im einsatz
zum vergleich in den usa waren es zu
diesem zeitpunkt bereits über 2000
geräte die unter anderem knapp 80
prozent aller prostata operationen
unterstützt haben warum sind systeme wie
da vinci also nicht auch in deutschland
schon längst viel verbreitet haben ein
grund könnten natürlich die hohen kosten
des systems seien darüber hinaus gibt es
aber auch einige paper die generell in
frage stellen ob roboter ob es wirklich
so viel besser sind wie behauptet
das swiss medical board konnte zb keine
klaren vorteile des verfahrens
feststellen und auch in dieser us
amerikanischen studie hier zeigen
traditionelle op es über mehrere tausend
gynäkologische eingriffe hinweg genau so
gute ergebnisse wie solche mit roboter
support außerdem ist es wichtig zu
erwähnen dass da vinci sowieso nur in
ganz bestimmten medizinischen
fachbereichen zum tragen kommt und
selbst dort längst nicht jede art von
behandlung mit davinci gemacht wird
abgesehen von den kosten sind eingriffe
mit davinci nämlich auch aufwendiger und
dauern länger der patient muss anders
vorbereitet werden
der roboter angesetzt und kalibriert
diese ganze prozedur rechnet sich
natürlich nur dann wenn eine op
überhaupt da vinci extreme präzision
erfordert dazu gehören operationen aus
dem bereich der urologie der gynäkologie
und sowas wie blinddarm entfernungen
nicht jeder op wird also in zukunft von
einem roboter unterstützt okay aber dann
bleib doch immer noch der vorteil der
fernsteuerung oder wenn ich zum beispiel
eine seltene krankheit habe oder einen
komplizierten tumor dann würde ich am
liebsten von den besten der besten
behandelt werden egal wo sie sich gerade
befinden
mit der vinci wäre das ja theoretisch
machbar ich könnte dann in jedem
beliebigen deutschen krankenhaus
operiert werden und die spezialistin
oder der spezialist würde dann zum
beispiel einfach aus kanada oder japan
dazu geschaltet werden und mich aus der
ferne operieren in dieser idee liegt
tatsächlich der ursprung der windschutz
denn der roboter wurde in den 90ern
unter anderem vom us militär entwickelt
division mit dem roboter sollten
chirurgen und chirurgen verwundete
soldaten in krisengebieten operieren
können ohne physisch anwesend zu sein
leider gestaltet sich die umsetzung
ferngesteuerte ob es aber nicht so
einfach
das hauptproblem ist hier die
datenübertragung bei einer verbindung
über mehrere tausend kilometer hinweg
entsteht zwangsläufig eine latenz eine
verzögerung die das arbeiten deutlich
erschwert tatsächlich wurden schon
einige op ist viel lob es sogar über
mehrere tausend kilometer durchgeführt
teilweise sogar mit ganz normalem
standard internet aber ohne eine
grundlegende verbesserung unserer
übertragungsnetze werden long distance
op es wohl nicht zum alltag
und wollen wir das überhaupt fühlen wir
uns als patient nicht auch in besseren
händen wenn die behandelnde personen vor
ort ist und im notfall eingreifen kann
stellen sie sich vor sie lege oder sie
wissen der operateur steht gerade auf
sitzt vorm fernseher und geht dann an
die konsole macht schon zuhause fertig
das kann schon ein bisschen was ja genau
die professionalität und das man beim
patienten selber da ist und vor allem
was ist wenn was passiert man trägt das
operative verantwortung und will
natürlich dann auch das was passiert ist
operieren oder manager ok die operation
ist vorbei die meisten leute sind weg
hier wurde schon aufgeräumt wir dürfen
jetzt allerdings noch mal mit dem da
vinci roboter selber operieren natürlich
nicht am patienten sondern nur am
trocken objekt man ausprobieren wie man
tatsächlich sich fühlt wenn man hier
operiert
[Musik]
es ist erst mal komplizierter also wenn
ich so mit dem hintern machen würde
würde ich schneller
jetzt habe ich die miteinander bewegt so
schlecht fürs tor
[Musik]
es ist gar nicht so einfach wie es
vielleicht aussah ich habe vorhin den
profis zugesehen wie konnte das direkt
macht und die wussten genau was sie tun
wenn man dann einmal da jetzt selber
dran sind ist es schon sehr schwierig in
so rund zu kommen und sich das im
dreidimensionalen raum vorzustellen
aber ja wie wir gehört haben mehrere
tausend operationen da kann man das dann
wahrscheinlich erstochen
okay vielleicht bin ich noch ein paar
übungsstunden von einer richtigen op
entfernt selbst ich habe gespürt wie
schnell sich mein gehirn daran gewöhnt
hat dass diese kleinen dinger wirklich
meine hände waren nicht damit dann dinge
gemacht habe es war sehr intuitiv für
die erfahrung an dieser stelle schon mal
ein ganz großes dankeschön an die
paracelsus-klinik gold sein bissendorf
und an das ganze team rund um dr da wo
die und dr sieht man ihr habt uns
wirklich alles möglich erklärt und war
unglaublich nett dankeschön dafür was
mir aber durch meinen kleinen test rät
auch sofort klar geworden ist nur weil
ich ein roboter habe bin ich nicht
automatisch ein super chirurg in das ist
wie beim autofahren wenn sie eine
verlage in der hand von einer 18 jährige
geben der gerade seinen führerschein
gemacht hat werden wahrscheinlich in den
nächsten baum küssen aber in der hand
von schumacher kann es schon was machen
und das sieht auch gut aus der sich auch
gerne an
man muss ja auch schon auch eine gute
operateur sein und dann auch
entsprechende übungen haben dann nicht
zitieren also für den operateur selber
ist es mit eins der größten
herausforderungen auch verfahren was uns
hilft und deswegen sind
er wünschte jeder operativ kennenlernen
bevor also voll robotino ps zum standard
werden wird es wahrscheinlich noch ein
bisschen dauern
wenn es überhaupt so weit kommt was wir
sehen konnten ist technologisch schon
sehr vielversprechend aber vor allem
fehlt es momentan einem gesunden
wettbewerb damit sich die potenziellen
vorteile des systems für die meisten
krankenhäuser auch rechnen
ich finde es aber persönlich mega
spannend und cool dass wir in einer zeit
leben in der menschen wirklich von
robotern operiert werden wie cool ist
das denn bin sehr gespannt wie sich das
alles noch weiterentwickeln würde dieses
video wurde unterstützt von niemandem
tatsächlich vielleicht ist euch
aufgefallen wir haben keine großen
sponsoren keine namen keine logos wenn
überhaupt seid ihr die unterstützer seid
ihr die sponsoren deren über page führen
unterstützt wir uns jeden monat mit
euren kleinen beträgen die dann zu etwas
großem werden und was uns dann
tatsächlich erlaubt solche videos wie
dieses hier zu machen selbst wenn wir
mal gerade keinen sponsor haben denn
tatsächlich war dieses video ziemlich
aufwendig wir sind zu zweit ganzen tag
lang nach düsseldorf gefahren haben da
in dem op gedreht haben mit chirurgen
gesprochen und ich glaube dass das viele
unterschätzen es auch die postproduktion
wir schneiden das nicht mal eben
zusammen sind tatsächlich viele viele
tage arbeit um mehrere leute dran sitzen
und durch euch können wir das
tatsächlich besser finanzieren deswegen
schon nach vielen vielen lieben dank an
alle fans die uns unterstützen wenn ihr
uns unterstützen wollt dann geht das
auch petra dot com / doktor watson das
geht los ab einem euro pro monat und das
könnt ihr jederzeit wieder kämpfen wenn
ihr wollt ab drei euro werdet ihr
namentlich in den videos erwähnt und
seit in den credits verewigt und ab 10
euro
seid ihr executive producer werdet auch
als solche in den credits genannt und
ihr könnt neue doktor watson videos vor
allen anderen seen und generell sobald
die software und support at habt ihr
zugriff auf den fett und kein bisschen
wie ein tessins videos sehen können
sehen wie es hier so läuft was passiert
eine sache ist mir der stelle noch
wichtig es geht hier wirklich darum zu
spenden also wirklich nur wenig geld
übrig habt dass ihr euch gerne spenden
wollt dann könnt ihr das gerne machen
aber wenn ihr sagt ihr habt ihr seid
studenten oder schüler und ich verdiene
noch nicht euer eigenes geld dann lass
es bitte behaltet das alle unsere videos
die haupt videos auf den oktober ziehen
sind für alle und immer kostenlos
verfügbar
wenn jetzt noch mehr videos über die
zukunft der medizin sehen wollt mal habe
ich hier gleich zwei davon einmal die
spritze ohne nadel und andere technische
innovationen in der medizin das könnt
ihr gerne hier oben sehen und da drunter
wie heute schon ki in der medizin
eingesetzt wird wie immer
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig
er drückt